I feel at a disadvantage with jannis as
my adversary because not only have I
ever tried to run an economy but sitting
here in Islington he is on his home turf
home pitch and I'm
not but I'm going to try and defend
capitalism but not the current form of
capitalism because I'm trained as an
anthropologist um and one of the things
anthropologists spend a lot of time
doing is look at the gap between what
people say they do and what they
actually do between rhetoric between the
rituals and symbols they aspired to and
the actual lived reality and the core of
my argument is that the capitalist flag
the flag of Adam Smith that Jan has
talked about has been waved around a lot
in recent years by politicians by
Business Leaders by financiers
yes by Financial journalists but what we
have today is not what Adam Smith
sketched
out to understand that you have to go
back and realize that there are two
books of Adam Smith and only one has
been focused on in recent years The
Wealth of Nations lays out a theory
about why competition is good I happen
to believe to channel I hate to say it
Boris Johnson by quoting Winston
Churchill that actually competition and
profit is the worst way to organize an
economy except for all the others that
have been tried I say that having lived
in the former Soviet Union where I did
my research and seen other other Visions
um playing out but when Adam Smith laid
out his two his vision of capitalism his
vision of Market forces he didn't use
the word capitalism it's vision of
markets he had two books The Wealth of
Nations about competition and trade and
the theory of moral sentiments um which
is one of The Inspirations for the moral
money column which I co-founded at the
financial times and that Vision
essentially argued that there were four
components you needed to make markets
effective you needed to have free access
to markets people had to be able to take
part in them you need to have free
access to prices people needed to know
what the prices were in a transparent
way you needed to have an alision of
ownership ship between the people who
managed Ventures and actually owned them
which in Adam Smith day were mostly
family-owned owned firms so it wasn't a
problem and you needed to have a shared
moral ethical and legal base which
basically provided a foundation for
people to have shared values and shared
trust remember the roots of the word
credit come from the Latin to trust and
without that it's very hard to have a
market now if you dial back and think
about what was happening two decades ago
on Wall Street you can see that all four
of those components were missing people
did not have equal access to the markets
because guess what it was powerful
cartels on Wall Street and the city of
London who were running the show they
didn't have access to prices because yes
you can get access to stock market
prices but there's many other prices in
finance that are not visible to The
Wider public there wasn't effective
allision of ownership and management
because guess what the people who were
supposedly owning companies which is all
of us for our Pension funds tended to
Outsource that to asset managers who
were largely asleep at the wheel and
didn't understand what was happening
inside companies or Banks and there
hasn't been a shared moral framework or
even one could argue a legal and ethical
framework essentially putting what's
been happening in business and finance
into the wider social context
anthropologists are obsessed with
context obsessed with a sense of
consequence of what business and finance
does I would argue that many of those
shortcomings are found in other areas of
modern capitalism such as the tech
sector which yanis just spoke about I'd
actually agree with you that there is a
fundamental problem of Monopoly power of
a lack of transparency
of a lack of access inside the tech
sector as well and so I would agree with
you that capitalism actually isn't
particularly effective there at the
moment because we don't actually have
that at the moment we have the gap
between rhetoric and
reality and yet I personally still think
that that vision of
competition that vision of using profits
to be reinvested back in growth that
idea that actually Innovation occurs
when you have some friction when you
have a sense of personal
responsibility that is still a good set
of principles to be using to be driving
an economy
forward so for those reasons I remain a
fan of Adam Smith when you look at both
books and I'll just leave you with two
last ideas which again infuses how I see
capitalism how I'd like to see
capitalism play out
as an anthropologist again I'm
fascinated by words and
language I don't know how many of you
know here where the word company comes
from originally I talk about it in my
book it originally comes from Latin from
old old Italian actually
cono meaning with bread because
companies were originally seen as groups
of people who ate together and then did
business together Sim I don't know how
many of you know where where the word
Finance comes from but it actually comes
from old French fer meaning to finish
which sounds completely bizarre because
people think that Finance is basically
never-ending Loops of money going round
and round like sugar in a candy floss
maker building a bigger and bigger path
of speculation that's kind of
meaningless but originally Finance was
about paying off blood debts and
finishing actual tangible commercial
transactions it was a means to an end
not an end in
itself so to go back to Adam Smith if
you put those two books together the
vision of capitalism that I uphold is
one where companies are recognized to be
about humans and groups of people
competing together building things
together and money is a means to an end
the fuel that drives forward the economy
and growth and I personally think that
is a vision that we should be upholding
and aspiring to
today
and I say last of all I realiz jannis
and I both got the dark blue shirt memo
so we end up agreeing more than we
disagreeing
sadly effortlessly
stylish I thought i' just um just pick
up a couple of points there to to
question both of you yanice I just just
trying to put together a list in my head
and it's a pretty obvious one but it
goes something like this KL Marx
Vladimir ilich Lenin Starin Buu uh any
number of post-war communist leaders and
supporters after the Great Rift in in
Europe of course in in 1939 to 45 1968
radicalism
maoism
and that on home turf Jeremy Corbin
um sort of in illustrious company um you
see that the the line of argument
there's and each of them has seen the
Death Rows of of capitalism in some form
and yet here we all are having a
discussion about whether we can fix it
what makes you think that this time it's
different Factor applies to
2021 you're quite right uh every
socialist and I count myself as one um
has always been like a stopped clock
that eventually tells the the right time
um you know we kept uh predicting a
massive Financial collapse ever since I
was you know 10 and it happened in 2008
So eventually you know all our
predictions come true it doesn't mean we
were right analytically about it um look
uh why do I think that U This Time It's
Different to quote famous
economist uh
first I'll repeat some some of the
things I said but in a different manner
hopefully
helpfully take what happened in the
summer of 2020 here in London I think it
was the 12th of August when you had the
announcement uh that uh your GDP fell by
more than 20% for the first time in the
history of British capitalism remember
that August
2020 uh the market expectations were for
a
fall of about 12 to 133% it was much
much more than that and yet 15 16
minutes later the LOM Stock Exchange
went up that has never happened before
in the history of capitalism why did it
happen for a very logical reason because
Market players thought oh my God 20 plus
then this immediately Nan seconds later
they thought okay if we're panicking the
bank of England are panicking so they're
going to print loads of money and they
will pump it in our Direction okay to
refloat the disaster so let's keep
buying okay now this is simply a little
tale that I tell in order to capture the
manner in which financial markets have
completely decoupled from really
existing capitalism and if you think
about it in 2018 we had a 1929 our
generation's 1929 the difference with
1929 was that unlike the Hoover
administration in the United States in
29 that let the banks
fall uh the G7 G20 April 2009 Gordon
Brown London they decided to refloat
them so they went into a spasm of
printing mountain ranges of money to
refloat the financial markets which they
did very successfully proof that if they
want to do something they do they do it
right but ever since the did that
uh and they did it in a staggered way
the European Central Bank really began
doing it in 2012 and then went all out
in 2015 with Mario dragy 1 of March but
the way I see it now capitalism has
completely been hooked on Central Bank
money and therefore you why is Jeff
Bezos $50 billion richer than he was at
the beginning of the pandemic it's not
the profits of Amazon of his businesses
it is the increase in the share market
because what happens is QE means that uh
you know the Central Bank prints money
they give it they effectively given a
high a larger overdraft to you know the
bar Barky Banks Deutsche banks of the
world they look at you people they say
oh no no we're not going to lend them
because they're hopeless so they pick up
the phone they call Volkswagen Z alstom
you know Google Apple and they say do
you want a few billion those people
don't need money because they already
have stashes of money which itself is a
problem because corporations should be
borrowing not not saving but they take
the money because it's free and they
take it and they go to the stock
exchange and they buy back their own
shares okay so now you have a a
bifurcation of uh of capitalism you have
the companies that maintain
profitability because it's not Monopoly
that they have for me Amazon you know um
General Motors had a monopoly or olop
Amazon is different it's a platform it
means that you exit capitalism you exit
the market and you go into a place that
where everything that sold or bought are
controlled by one company one algor very
different stick because there's quite a
lot in there let Jullian come back let
on on that QE qu of easing money
slushing out point just one one final
phrase then I can throw it over to you
one final phrase so if if what I'm
saying holds water
then Adam Smith is simply not relevant
he's as relevant as KL Marx was in the
Soviet Union when you were there in
other words not at
all